in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show you that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us for many people especially
children a ride in the back of an
ambulance can be a very scary thing it's
scary if you're an adult - Jamie yuccas
introduces us to a Minnesota paramedic
who found the magic solution when an
emergency call comes in paramedic ivan
mazurka wits rolls out ready to make
life-saving decisions he's passionate
about his profession but still finds
time for a little sleight of hand Ivan's
tricks are a regular part of the job on
calls where kids are involved in order
to help them stay calm what is magic do
for a child it breaks the ice
it takes down on their wall their
association of an ambulances blood and
needles that can literally turn kids
worst day into one of the best days in
the last five years he's responded to
more than 4,000 emergencies still ivan
remembers the worst call of his career
he was screaming for his dad over and
over again and this kid was just
absolute fear I watched a five-year-old
boy go from screaming for his father to
lifeless for the first time in my career
I actually felt powerless that tragedy
drove him to search for a way to better
connect with kids my name is Ivan okay
that's when he realized his boyhood love
for magic just might hold the key so he
stopped at the Eagle magic store the
oldest shop in the country and signed up
for lessons is there anything we
shouldn't be looking at well I mean if I
gave away now he works magic in the back
of his ambulance I was saying did you
hit how many two three wait what as I
learned a couple coin tricks and I was
terrible with it but you know I didn't
have to be good at it I just had to be
good enough for that kid for one kid
of course some calls are too critical
for card tricks but after he delivers a
patient safely to the ER he'll still
take the time to distract a child from
the scary task at hand one time I was
doing magic tricks in the ER and I was
doing it while they were starting an IV
on the kid and the kid definitely still
felt the IV but he was still interested
in what I was doing more keep my
enchanting mom feeling better does it
make your job any easier of course
anytime we can distract children when
they're hurt or ill it just makes them
so much easier to treat and the parents
feel so much more reassured lift up your
arms and until his next call the amateur
magician will continue to make the fear
disappear what really matters maybe
isn't the medicine that's how you treat
people and you just reminded me of that
even the staff at Mercy Hospital can't
unlock the secret that's God is it over
here no it's actually all I want to do
is be good at my job and if it means me
finding another way to be a better
paramedic which is doing magic tricks
for kids by all means I'm going to do
that surprising kids to soothe their
souls for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Minneapolis Minnesota it's
amazing what a difference that can make
for a kid if you're in the back of an
ambulance it just changes it magic is
real you know I've tried it and I
couldn't do it yes